antibiotika resistenz weltweit sterben
rund 700.000 menschen aufgrund einer
antibiotika resistenz im jahr 2050 bis
zehn millionen sein
die medizin muss also schnellstmöglich
eine lösung finden aber die menschen
verbreitung scheinen uns da einen strich
durch die rechnung zu machen herzlich
willkommen bei klick vom 2
es wird langsam richtig eng in jedem
zweiten horror survival film oder spiel
gibt es an einem punkt das
lebensrettende und alles wieder ins lot
rückende heilmittel dass es gilt zu
bekommen um auf ein happy end
zuzusteuern
im echten leben war bisher oft das
letzte mittel wenn nichts anderes mehr
geholfen hat ein antibiotikum im laufe
der zeit wurde die wirkung dieses
wirkstoffes aber oftmals einfach nur
ausgenutzt um in möglichst kurzer zeit
wieder voll belastbar sein ärzte werden
zunehmend von eltern zum verschreibung
von antibiotika für deren an einer
leichten grippe erkrankten kinder
gedrängt der einsatzbereich der
antibiotika reicht mittlerweile weit
über den vorerst zugedachten bereich
hinaus in der tierhaltung werden
antibiotika gegeben damit die tiere gar
nicht erst krank werden die antibiotika
resistenten sind soweit ich freut die
noch nie zuvor
forscher der chinesischen akademie der
wissenschaft haben jetzt ziemlich
erschreckendes entdeckt entlang einer
zusammengenommen vier kilometer langen
küstenlinie in der nähe von
flussmündungen haben sie ein bisher
unbekanntes ausmaß der resistenten
feststellen müssen
in den schlamm sedimenten schließen die
wissenschaftler in bakterien auf
unmengen an antibiotika resistenten
genen in forschern zufolge reiche die
menge von knapp 900.000 bis zu 180
millionen kopien programm element zitat
die gefundenen resistenzgene machen
gegen nahezu alle antibiotika klappen
immun die bei menschen und tieren
eingesetzt werden ihre vielfalt ist
sogar höher als in proben von
chinesischen schweinefarm auch gene die
gleich gegen mehrere antibiotika klassen
resistent machen waren häufig und in
vielen varianten vorhanden so die
experten der chinesischen akademie der
wissenschaften wie schon anfangs gesagt
es wird eng was machen wir denn wenn wir
nichts und niemanden mehr helfen können
was sagt ihr dazu
ab in die kommentare und hier könnte mir
ein abo aufs auge drücken und einen auf
die glocke geben bis dann bleibt dran
und das nächste wiederum